Allah says in the Quran in surah Bakar
chapter number two verse number 197
that the woman that the man
is the garment of the woman and the
woman is the garment of the men. That
means the husband and wife they are
garments unto one another. What is the
duty and the role of the garment? It is
to cover the body. It is to beautify. It
is to protect. So the men and women, the
husband and wife, they cover each
other's faults. They protect each other
and they guard one another and they
beautify one another. It is like the
role of hand and glove.
Allah says in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number two 228
the women have rights
same as against them on equitable terms
but the men have a degree of advantage.
That means this verse clearly says that
the rights of the men and women are the
same except the men have a degree of
advantage. referring to it that in the
family the man is the leader. You can't
have two leaders. If you have two
leaders in a country there'll be chaos.
As Allah says if there are two gods
there would be chaos in the universe. So
the leaders should be one. So but men
have the same the women have the same
rights as against them on equitable
terms but the men have a degree of
advantage otherwise the rights of men
and women are equal.
Furthermore,
if we analyze
that in Islam,
as far as a wife is concerned,
the role and duty,
the social rights of male and female are
the same.
And it is further said
that
for a wife
she when the hadith says that the man if
he's a leader of the family even in
Islam she's called asul B that means
she's the lord of the house she's the
leader of the family but she takes care
of the house.
Let's discuss
the social rights of the mother in
Islam.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Isra
chapter number 17 verse number 23 and
24. We have enjoyed other human beings.
We have ordained that you should worship
none but Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
that you should be kind to your parents
and if one of them or both of them reach
old age do not say a word of contempt
don't say off to them
nor repel them
but speak to them in good words
speak to them in good manners and
address them with honor and pray to the
Lord God and lower your wing of humility
and pray to the Lord that bless them as
they cherish me in childhood. So after
worshiping Allah subhanana wa ta'ala,
Allah says you have to be kind to your
parents.
You can't even say to them
and do not repel them.
You can't use disrespectful words.
and pray to thy Lord to cherish them as
they blessed you in the childhood.